explosive action scenes a sympathetic
sherlock and teen romance are just some
of the biggest changes the anola homes
movie made when adapting the original
novels
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're exploring 11 major
differences between the netflix movie
and nancy springer's a nola holmes book
the case of the missing marquis
film and book spoilers ahead so take
care during interviews for the movie
henry cavill has spoken about how his
sherlock diverges from what he calls the
traditional misogynistic genius we're
used to seeing
as a nola softens him and opens up his
heart
this is very different from the way
sherlock's portrayed in springer's first
enola homes mystery as well
in the book the world famous detective
certainly has a low opinion of women
banging on about their irrationality
untrustworthiness the innate untidiness
of their minds and even his own sister
anola's limited cranial capacity
and book sherlock certainly never
reminisces about his memories of anola's
childhood and her pine-cone dog dash as
cavill does in the film
making sherlock more openly sympathetic
towards his sister in the movie
and giving him as caval says more warmth
kindness and humanity
you've become quite the detective in
earlier creates a sharper contrast
between him and mycroft than in the
novel where the brothers are pretty much
as curt and imperious as each other
both passing plenty of judgment on anola
her mother and how they live
and although we do see some similarities
between sherlock and anola in the novel
with her even deliberately mimicking him
a few times the fact that in some ways
they're like two peas in a pod as cavil
says
is emphasized more in the film sherlock
even
ends up wanting to be his sister's
guardian which really accelerates the
way he grows to respect enola which
happens much later in the series of six
books the movie adds lots more action
and intrigue to the already very
enjoyable original story
for example anola and chukesbury cross
paths in much
different circumstances in the film than
in the book where they only meet three
quarters of the way through the story
when they're kidnapped and tied up on a
boat in london before escaping and being
chased through the streets of the
capital
in the movie however tewksbury pops up
much earlier a mere 20 minutes into the
film's two-hour run time when he tumbles
out of a carpet bag
and then he and anola end up being
pursued by a man trying to murder him
before they make a daring escape from a
moving train
chukesbury's early on-screen
introduction brings the mystery of his
disappearance forward in the story
and means that he and anola spend much
more time together than in the book
where nola travels alone to london by
train dressed as a widow
rather than as a young boy the film also
adds masses of intrigue to chukesbury's
tale
in the original story chuki as his
mother calls him hates being treated
like a baby and wants to run away to sea
so leaves for london where two men
kidnap him to get ransom money from his
mum and dad
both of whom are still alive unlike the
movie there's no big conspiracy
involving his grandmother trying to have
her progressive son and grandson
murdered to prevent them from increasing
voting rights among the general
population
by adding the grandmother's scheming to
the plot the film raises the stakes
putting tewksbury's life immortal danger
on several occasions
and also having the fate of the
country's progress rest in his and
anola's hands
extra drama is also added to the story
of anola's mother in the film
eudoria is described as a free thinker
and a proponent of female suffrage in
the book
but there's no gunpowder plot or any
clues to a store of explosives in
limehouse lane
and although anola is attacked and
kidnapped on the streets of london
there's no attempted drowning
or literally explosive fight scene like
in the movie
another interesting difference is that
in the book one of anola and
shukesbury's london kidnappers actually
plays a dual role
as he also masquerades as a female
medium who first claims she can help
chukesbury's family find their missing
son
and later recommends they pay the very
large ransom when the demand arrives
the film sees mycroft paccanola off to
his friend miss harrison's finishing
school for young ladies where she's
taught how to walk speak laugh and sew
as well as to act and think as she's
told
this is another change from the books
where there's no miss harrison character
and a nola never goes to
boarding school though book mycroft does
arrange to send
anola away to school to correct her wild
ways and nola tricks everyone into
thinking she's leaving for school then
runs away to continue her search for her
missing mother instead right at the
start of the movie anola turns to the
camera and speaks directly to us in the
audience
now where to begin while in the novel
she doesn't talk straight to us
readers in the same way the story is
told from her point of view
so the film's choice to have her break
the fourth world throughout giving us a
running commentary on her adventures
is a nice way of bringing to life how
the book is told through anola's eyes
and characters connecting directly with
their audiences in that way is something
director harry bradbeer certainly has
plenty of experience with from his work
on the tv series fleabag where creator
and star phoebe waller bridge regularly
tears down the fourth wall
in fact it was while watching fleabag
that screenwriter jack thorne got the
idea to use that device in the movie
as a way to get inside the mind of
someone who spends the majority of her
time alone
in bradfield's mind the main reason to
break the fourth wall was anola's
loneliness as that meant we were her
only friend and she needed to
communicate with us a striking
difference between the original story
and the film is the way the movie plays
up a blossoming romance between anola
and chukesbury who's aged up from 12
years old in the book where there's no
real hint of any such crush
in the film chukesbury even knows
anola's true identity whereas in the
book she deliberately never tells him
who she really is
and he only discovers she's related to
sherlock holmes by accident
booker nola even disappears from
tewksbury's life without so much as a
goodbye
as she suddenly has to avoid being
caught by her brother
she does rather regret having to leave
chuuki so abruptly and there are
pointers towards a possible friendship
between the two and little hints at
their similarities like their reasons
for running away and the hard lessons
they learn about the lives of the poor
in london
but there's nothing in the novel like
tewksbury's invitation for anola to live
with his family
or their parting kiss or any of the
clear signals that they're very much
kindred spirits
and that louis partridge's chuke spree
will pop up again in the new film
franchise
unlike his book counterpart who only
appears in the first story
you're not rid of me yet but i count to
quick through my request of bazel ever
enola's relationship with her mother is
much closer in the film than it is in
the book
in the movie anola tells us that they
spend a lot of time together and that
her mum taught her
much of what she knows including reading
science and sports
it's just the two of us and it was
wonderful in the book however while her
mother
encourages her daughter's reading
drawing and general independence and
even taught her to ride a bike anola
specifically says mum and i
seldom interfered in one another's
concerns given the movie cast well-known
actress helena bonham carter as a nola's
mother
though it's hardly surprising that the
filmmakers decided to expand on the
mother-daughter relationship
and beefing up their familial bond and
their activities together
also gives a nola a backstory that's
more visually interesting than sitting
reading or wandering around the estate's
grounds alone
which is how she tells us she spent a
lot of time in the book
in the original story enola attributes
at least part of the emotional distance
between herself and her mum to the fact
that she was born what she calls
indecently late
in her mother's life creating a scandal
and a burden
in fact when eudoria goes missing in the
novel she's 64 years old and anola is
14.
at the time of filming bonan carter was
53 and while she wasn't visibly aged up
to play eudoria the movie does increase
anola's age slightly making her 16 years
old which is the same age as actress
millie bobby brown at the film's release
in 2020
the filmmakers are very likely hoping to
kick off a franchise with this
using the six books in the series so it
makes sense for brown not to have to
play a very young teenager for what
could be several years as she grows up
a significant change when it comes to
the end of the story is that there's no
emotional reunion between anola and her
mum by the final chapter of the book
instead things are left relatively up in
the air with anola simply receiving a
coded message from a mum in a newspaper
which interprets using the language of
flowers as meaning that eudoria is
living a contented life
wandering free with gypsies in stark
contrast the movie has eudoria turn up
unexpectedly at nola's rented room in
london to explain her absence
i couldn't bear to have this world be
your future so i had to fight this
somewhat teary scene
wraps up the mother's story just about
enough for now
and possibly even for future films if
the filmmakers or bottom carter decide
against bringing the character back
yet it also leaves things open enough if
everyone wants her to return
thank you for your irises now if you
ever need me
i'll be looking out for them now if like
me you can't wait for another anola
homes film there were some huge clues in
the movies ending that reveal what we
can look forward to in the sequel
tap here to watch my full video on that
or follow the link in the video
description
so what were your favorite moments in
the movie and was there anything you
didn't like
leave your thoughts in the comments
below if you enjoyed this don't forget
to leave a thumbs up and subscribe for
all my upcoming videos
tap left to watch my next nola homes
video or tap right for something else
you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers
you